the new england patriots had won six in
a row they
they stumbled into a pothole on sunday
in nashville no one really saw it coming
except maybe the titans mike frable had
that team ready to go he knew that they
had to match the patriots in all three
phases with physicality take away their
ability to gain yards quickly and easily
jump on those easy access throws as
frabel explained them to me in the
aftermath of the game and
they shut them down and they beat them
down and now the patriots have to figure
out where they go from here we're gonna
have tom curran on it momentarily needs
to tighten the the uh string between the
tin cans we need to get a little better
a little better connection before tom
kern we also have an informal pool going
as to which inappropriate word he's
going to say today i'm going to text him
stats my pick and then split the money
with him when he says it
don't give him ideas he doesn't need the
help
no no he doesn't he's usually good for
at least one uh and the patriots are
good for one of those kinds of games mid
to late season last year it was a monday
nighter against the dolphins where miami
surprised them so they know how to shrug
it off they know how to get past it and
they'll be fine i think they probably
wish that they were playing this weekend
because you get back on the horse you
get that win and you feel like balance
has been restored
to the patriot organization so they have
to wait a little bit longer but chances
are when they get the jets coming out of
the buy and the jets are on a buy also
that is going to be the moment where the
patriots feel good about themselves
going down the stretch still working to
get tom curran on an acceptable
connection i'm starting to suspect foul
play he can't say anything appropriate
if he can't say anything i have a
question learn from experience yes stats
so you've talked a lot about how the afc
east has been historically weak during
this patriots run of dominance how much
does it help them that they never have
to feel the pressure after a loss like
this of anyone in the division ever
catching them
well look it is so many different ways
that having no real competitor in your
division helps you we talked last week
about how when you're getting ready to
play a great team the next week you can
spend some of your time when you're
getting ready for buffalo looking ahead
to the packers game
and when you don't have those six games
every year that you look at and say wow
what are what are we gonna do against
these three opponents twice each it it
makes your life easier in a lot of ways
tom curran makes our life easier when it
helps us understand the new england
patriots he joins us now good morning
tom
mike you overstate that stuff
religiously and it's interesting on the
surface of it but it turns into
propaganda if you don't go into the full
context of how the patriots perform
outside their division relative to
inside their division in july i wrote a
story about this their winning
percentage since 2003 outside the
division virtually identical 780 to
inside the division
so it's overstated that the patriots in
the asc east profit there because they
go out and they kick ass at the same
rate
not to say that those teams are good not
to say that the fact that chad
pennington is the best quarterback
brady's i've had to deal with in the
division
isn't a blemish but let's be realistic
as well
it doesn't matter what division they're
in since 2003 if they were in the afc
north nfc west afc west it would look
probably
fairly similar
i i don't know that i would say fairly
similar i mean if they were in the same
division with the steelers for the last
15 years if they're in the same division
division there
no no but i'm saying that if they were
in a division with
one or two other teams that were
actually able to walk and chew gum at
the same time those would be six games
per year they'd have to be concerned
about i'm not saying they're bad out of
the division i mean they're not six and
ten
yeah but the angles of teams they've had
to be concerned about out there in
pittsburgh
but but look the steelers have had the
ravens that they've had to deal with and
the bengals the steelers have two other
teams in their division that are a
threat every year the patriots have no
threat they have no threat
how have the steelers fared against the
patriots since 2003 they regularly get
their ass kicked up between their ears
so if the steelers were in the same
division as the patriots then most
likely mike tomlin would have been
ushered out the door because he couldn't
win the division
but that's what you're suggesting then
that you put the paper so you're saying
you're saying the patriots if you would
put them in any other division they'd be
the same team they've been for the last
18 years
oh we got to get to one of these
distilling and contra and uh
and that's what you're saying i'm not
you're accusing me of spreading
propaganda you're suggesting that they
would dominate any division in the nfl
very
very what i said was very clear so don't
do this so what you're saying is
because when people do that they
understand they're going to try and
contort something and it's very habitual
these days where don't you excuse me
super simplified so now turn your radio
down
turn the radio down
to change your station uh
now that you got me warmed up why didn't
anybody ask belichick about dion lewis
yesterday
oh yeah i know we really missed the boat
on that because he would have said you
know what beyond i'll pay you something
you still have to ask him
mike i swear they put out the press
conference information
the media relations folks do i'll send
you the number and you can get on these
conference calls since you're so good
all 32 teams you can jump in and you can
because you're such a great ombudsman
you can jump in
hey hey
hey
hey tom tom when they were doing the nfl
media conference calls last year three a
week i was always asking a pain in the
ass question so don't don't lump me in
with the people are going to tiptoe on
eggshells because they're afraid of
making the great power powerful bill
belichick upset because that's not how i
play it and you know that
well i think that you understand too
that
what ends up happening that
the dance you have to dance is
if you're a beat writer on that
conference call and i didn't happen to
be on the conference call yesterday
because it doesn't yield great things
and i'm working on things that hopefully
people will be more fascinated by then
we didn't coach well we didn't play well
so as a result what you have to do is
walk that tightrope between asking some
questions that will engage them while
also trying to get information and at
some point if you ask bill bjorn lewis
said you guys are cheap and that's why
you got your ass kicked
you know that's basically going to end
the conversation now even if it does you
got a story in
in and of itself so i understand what
you're saying but you're just mad
because you wanted to vulture in and get
a story and you weren't able to do it
because nobody asked the question i did
it's not listen don't don't accuse me of
vulturing when you send me every story
you publish saying please please write
something about this
how many times have i done that since
the season started
well because you know when you do it
that that guarantees i'm not gonna write
it really simple question
you sent me five messages about some
mccourty story that you had five
five right
okay so how many times
overall this is once i bought it
i know do you like it or do you not like
i get i get very sensitive about this
vulture stuff do you like it or do you
not like it when i publicize your work
at pft
yes or no
yes tom
okay yeah thank you
you know we have we have we have a pool
today as to which inappropriate words
you're going to say i was going to text
you my pick and split the money with you
but that probably would be cheating
oh for christ's sake is that
inappropriate you can't say that
no that that that's not on the list hey
um but back to belichick there is a way
to ask the question
got to be a way to say hey did you see
what dion lewis said yesterday like kind
of like you know in a demeanor's like
how ridiculous is this hey how about
deon lewis's comment just a coach you
got anything to say about that anybody
just kind of grunts and mumbles at least
you check the box and you've asked the
question and you can do it in a way
where he's not upset with you and and
gives you a hard time for the next three
weeks
awesome mike honestly i
you might be
in a position again where you got
a hair across your posterior about that
question but over the course of time i
think we do do a pretty good job of
asking the guy the questions that
absolutely positively have to be asked
if it's a swing and a miss on a
conference call after an ass beating
in tennessee on dion lewis's comment so
be it but
it's a cantankerous guy who keeps track
of who asks the questions that are
irritating and i think what's ended up
happening by and large too unfortunately
for younger people coming up in the
business i could ask those questions
from 97 to 20 really 2012 2013
and not have to feel like okay this
could turn into a clip that's passed
around for the next
36 hours and i still don't mind if that
happens but you have to understand that
if you're a younger person in the
business you're going to sit there and
say do i want to get dunked on by
belichick here
and end up being lampooned in my local
market by people who say i'm a dink for
trying but if you don't ask a stupid
question if you don't ask if you ask if
it's one thing to ask mike
a really dumb question whatever whatever
point you're making is going to be a
good one dumb questions oftentimes
obvious questions oftentimes have to be
asked because they yield the best
answers mike giardi after the kansas
city game in 2014 he and i agreed
i was going to ask was was brady benched
for a performance or to get him out of
the game
and belichick kind of answered that and
then mike ziardi who's now at the nfl
network said i'll take the second one
which was will you evaluate the
quarterback position because during that
game
there was an avalanche of concern and
speculation that this was it for brady
and you had to move on from them so mike
asked the question and to this day
people still say oh you're the one that
asked that question it needed to be
asked it was asked belichick rolled his
eyes and we have a meme forever
that mike sometimes says you know what i
was just doing my job there but you
don't want to be that guy do you
understand what i'm saying there but you
have to ask me i think i i personally
tom i personally think you shouldn't
care whether you're that guy that's my
own belief maybe i'm wrong but you
shouldn't care because
it's the life you've chosen from time to
time you're going to be that guy and
that just goes with the territory
and i've been that guy before you've
been that guy before everybody's going
to wrap their brains around it and we'll
be that guy or that girl at some point
where they're asking the question
hopefully
but
it's
the tenor is different here you know
that come on up
well
i think i think the one consolation for
all of us is
well i'm not gonna say it uh um
it relates to who we cover there are
others we could be covering right now
that would be far more problematic and a
far more tenuous minefield than than
what you're dealing with with bill
belichick that's all i'm saying about it
i'm not saying anything more
okay you know what i'm talking about
no
i'm trying to get you hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports